thanks for joining us for security 209
cloud posture and workload protection
with security command center premium
i'm timothy peacock a product manager
here at google cloud i look after our
threat detection capabilities and in my
spare time i co-host the cloud security
podcast by google i'll be joined today
by dr jason voshall director of product
and solution security at xero
if you're interested in learning how to
protect your organization's use of
google cloud as a platform and protect
your workloads on top this session is
for you we have a packed agenda today an
overview of scc premium for those of you
new to the product a deep dive with our
friend jason from zebra and a lightning
round of announcements from across the
security command center platform miss
config and threat detection teams let's
dive right in
security command center premium brings
together in one central tool security
insights across your organization and
across the security life cycle
i think of scc premium as providing four
pillars of value for security teams
first asset and resource tracking
staying current with resource creation
update and deletion can be a challenge
in public clouds if you choose to give
engineering teams flexibility in
creating new services security command
center's cloud asset inventory makes it
really easy for organizational admins to
stay aware of what's changing inside
their org and easily query for deleted
and changed assets second hardening
misconfiguration and vulnerability
detection thanks to our real-time asset
updates scc premium provides real-time
misconfiguration detection cloud
security posture management cspm is a
must-have for security teams in cloud
security command center premium provides
out-of-the-box actionable posture
insights for our top gcp services
understanding and responding to
misconfiguration exposure is crucial for
preventing breach in cloud
the third pillar is threat detection and
we all know that despite our best
investments in hardening bad guys are
still going to try to do bad things talk
a lot more about detecting threats in
just a minute
fourth and finally scc premium helps you
tie your success in cloud security
classroom management back to leading
compliance standards not only do our
findings map to leading standards we
also provide the right tooling in the
platform to help you report on your
compliance across your organization now
let's look in depth at two of these
areas first hardening and then threat
detection
sec premium provides out of the box
platform and workload hardening our
posture findings are like i said
generated in real time and come with
remediations instructions making these
insights usable and actionable by
engineering teams and project owners who
are maybe not security experts above the
infrastructure layer we're now bringing
in operating system vulnerability
insights thanks to our partnership with
google's vm manager service users can
expect to see more updates on sdc's
presentation of cve detection from a
couple of other teams from google cloud
really soon
finally on top of those common
vulnerability insights scc premium also
provides the same web app scanning for
obasa's top 10 vulnerabilities as we use
ourselves in-house to protect google our
web security scanner is even easier to
use than ever with automated discovery
and scanning of your web apps all this
comes together to help security teams
proactively secure both their cloud
environment and their workloads running
on top without bringing in third-party
dependencies exposures and risk and with
that let's turn to talking about the
most unwanted of third parties with a
quick look at threat detection in cloud
a few years ago at conferences we all
got to feel very smart and smug by
saying oh the cloud is just someone
else's computer
the truth is in cloud there's a lot more
than just someone else's computer we
have new planes of attack surface and
with them new opportunities for
instrumentation
at the same time as the world of cloud
has brought tremendous change to the
security job our needs as security
professionals haven't really changed all
that much we're still focused on keeping
data confidential guaranteeing integrity
and ensuring availability
tolstoy wrote that quote all happy
families resemble one another every
unhappy family is unhappy in its own way
today's major public clouds are our
proverbial unhappy families adversaries
attack and pivot through clouds
differently and security teams need deep
cloud specific expertise to detect the
most dangerous threats in their
environments with security command
center premium our customers get access
to the same real-time threat detection
as google uses to protect its own use of
google cloud
they say all models are wrong but some
are useful here i offer what is
definitely wrong but a hopefully useful
six layer model for thinking about
protect surface in cloud environments
scc premium offers detection modules at
each layer of the six layer cake with
special emphasis on detecting identity
compromise and protecting kubernetes
workloads at runtime we handle platform
threat detection with our real-time log
processing service event threat
detection and workload threat detection
with our container threat detection
service we'll talk more about some new
capabilities in both of those services
in just a bit
with that i want to welcome our guest
today dr jason vishal of zebra
technologies jason thanks so much for
joining us today
thanks for having me tell our audience a
little bit about yourself your role in
the org and what your company does ah
absolutely so uh i'm dr jason vouschel
i'm the director for product and
solution security for zebra technologies
uh zebra may be the biggest smallest
company you've never heard of um
everything from scanning a package to
tracking an asset from point a to point
b that's the products we put out and my
responsibility and accountability is to
make sure those products we put out
are as secure as possible good example
if any of you have ever gotten a package
delivered to you and has a barcode on it
that tracking from where it was all the
way to around your doorstep was using
zebra technology's products and possibly
solutions as well and so my job is to
again make sure that everything we do
with that is as secure as possible
that's an amazing impact that a company
like that has so invisibly so they say
to start secure uh stories at the
beginning so could you tell the audience
a little bit about getting started with
security command center premium how long
that took and what it was like rolling
it out to different business units yeah
it did take some time i think with any
new product that comes into play there's
always some resistance at first people
are used to doing things a certain way
uh but with the google command center
we use a lot of gcp google cloud
platform in the solutions that we build
the old ways of trying to make sure that
secure the apps on top of it is secure
tracking the inventory of what we have
took a little bit of time but as we
progressed forward it really helped good
example we had a customer during an rfp
or request for proposal discussion and
we were stepping through they're asking
us well how are you securing this how
are you doing this and at one point we
said oh we're using the google security
command center and on top of this
application and they stopped and went
well i don't think we need to ask the
next 10 or 20 questions because they
knew about this product and they knew
that those questions were being answered
already and so with that when that took
a hold when customers started to realize
yeah you're using that our internal
teams went that's a lot faster
we can answer questions quicker we can
make sure the risk is reduced or to an
acceptable amount we need it to be and
with that we were able to get better
internal adoption you know you always
want to you know carry that big stick
around but you never want to swing it
you want you want the teams internally
to to want to use it to show them the
value and after a little bit of that you
know getting over the hump having a
customer go yeah that makes a lot easier
having the sales teams realize hey you
just answered an rfp quicker on security
because you're using this product
they're happier about it too we got a
lot of quicker adoption uh much easier
it also helped a great deal and i think
we'll dive into this a bit more in a sec
but uh being able to
give those teams back feedback uh hey we
found something and here's how you can
go fix it and here's how quick we gave
it to you and not getting a lot of fun
or you know a lot of cloudy stuff pun
fully intended uh for those teams so
that that does help across the board
yeah so let's dive in on that because
one of the things that comes up for me
with my customers is really how do they
scale their security operations as they
grow their cloud footprint one of the
features that we built uh really two
things here
to help address that one is what we call
scoped or delegated views of sec where
you can give the teams responsible for a
project or folder a view of their
findings in sec and the other is packing
a lot of detail and remediation
instructions into the posture findings
so that non-expert teams can really
respond to them so how's it going
rolling out that delegation of posture
issues to teams yeah so i don't know if
anybody's have the the old school way of
how do i you know i i t or some team
finds a bunch of vulnerabilities and
they want to give that to the
engineering teams and say go fix it uh
you know in the past they might have
gotten a spreadsheet or log into a
website and it's just
like a plethora of data and you know
anybody who looks at that goes like my
head hurts i i forgot what happened and
they're kind of dismisses
with the security command center the
ability to
focus in on you know this business unit
for this project so you know you're not
looking at every project just hey this
business unit this project
here are the things we're finding for
you to look at it cuts right to the
chase and i think being able to give
those teams or delegate to a certain
engineering team or security team
only what they need to see they don't
need to see everything in fact that they
do you know they're looking at the
squirrel trying to figure out where it's
going they can focus on that and they
can fix it a lot quicker right they
don't it's not too overburdened so with
that it's helped us speed up production
in many cases as because as we're moving
and we'll talk about shift left in a
second as we're moving that further into
the development life cycle we're finding
things quicker and we're only showing
the teams this is what you need to fix
and so it feels a lot quicker for them
let's talk about shift left because
we've got a lot of different sessions on
shift left at this year's next we've got
talks about supply chain security and
securing that could you tell us a little
bit how you see scc's hardening work
supporting your organization shift left
efforts yeah so shift left for anyone
who's not familiar hopefully everyone is
it means putting security uh earlier in
the development life cycle so as you're
even dreaming about a product that you
want to build you're thinking security
almost up front right away and so this
tool allows us so as we stand up even a
development a non-production instance we
stand up gcp we put the app on top of it
that security command center is still
scanning that still taking a real time
type of look into what we're doing and
we're able to fix those items quicker
and everybody knows when you shift left
because if i find availability late in
the game it's about to go out the door
and suddenly i realize oh no the
foundation's cracked on this house we
already built it's a little late to fix
the foundation now or if i'm going to
fix it it's going to cost me quite a bit
and so we really want to do those things
early on or left in the process the
command center allows us to find those
vulnerabilities quickly um all during
the process so we're not like you know
moving 10 feet and then doing a check
it's every time we're making a little
move it's always checking on us we can
say hey we found something
we'll take care of that right away it
helps actually speed up
the development life cycle while keeping
the product secure and that's very
important for us it helps us get the
product out the door quicker which means
our customers have it when they need it
and that's most important for us
that's uh that's such a nice story
around both helping with security as
well as helping with development
velocity so often those are uh intention
could we also talk a little bit about
how this is being used your organization
for threat detection and how that's gone
for your teams
yeah so uh one of the nice things we
like to to look at threat detection
tons of tools in the world everyone's
going oh i can i can find out what's
going on here
the hardest part for me uh false
positives
you see something hey we think there's a
threat at the door well is it or is it
not and if you're making me put a
resource on it to go investigate it
you know if you're chewing up resources
i can't expand my teams
the security command center
in my opinion has driven that false
positive rate down quite a bit uh even
with a little bit of tuning that we can
do with the help from google to help
tune that as well so when we get an
actual threat or detection of a threat
it feels more real you know we'll say in
the past you know you get a threat
detection maybe there's a 40 50 60
confidence when we see them now through
the security command center we're in the
high 90s on the confidence of yes that
is an actual threat it is actionable
it's an event let's go take care of that
what does that naturally do it frees up
our resources to do things that are uh
more important you know more risk
adverse as opposed to chasing chasing
ghosts chasing fud
so that helps us a great deal provides
confidence in the product it also helps
us even when we're talking to our
customers telling them yes we're using
this tool okay what kind of things
you're looking for we look for this
we're able to knock them down as quickly
and move to the next next uh next
problem under billiard threat that
possibly comes up
also getting to the false positive piece
it does allow again it frees up those
resources which that means they can go
look at other things so as teams are
developing
a project
we're not chasing the ghost we're
looking at real threats and we can get
back to looking at is there a
misconfiguration are we not aligned with
a benchmark is there a standard we're
not aligned to and fix those things to
keep it hardened and not just chasing
things around
oh that's awesome i want to touch on one
area before we wrap up which is the user
interface
we've made a lot of changes since you
know some people started using the
product i understand uh you may have
seen the more recent versions we've got
a lot of good changes coming soon how's
your team finding the ui
yeah so
you and i have talked about this before
i don't like to call it a ui i like to
call it a ufi or a user friendly
interface the ability for anyone to just
log in on a whim and not have to crack
open a 16 page or 160 page guide that
looks like some major book
and just kind of get to where you want
to get to is extremely important so as a
director you know i'm not in the tool
every day right our teams our sec ops
division is in there looking what they
need to do they're more advanced on it
but when we have something come up or
leadership ask a question on jason
what's our what's our security posture
what's our risk look like or we have a
customer that says we would like to know
a little bit more about you know what
are you doing with your vulnerabilities
how often do you see things as a
director i can have the team open it up
i can look inside and without really
knowing much more than just my technical
space
i can figure out what's going on that
dashboard fairly quick and i can tell
you that that you get user-friendly
interface is is very beneficial i can
get an ai as a director can get an
answer really quick without having to
know the technical details of it now of
course there's some things that those
that team is better for uh but from
where i'm sitting i can get an answer
quick i can tell our leadership our
customers are even our internal people
that need those answers even from where
i'm sitting so i'm very much a fan of
your ufi
jason i i love that answer and with
apologies to directors of security
everywhere i think what we just heard is
that our user interface is so easy even
a director can use it uh jason thank you
so much for joining us today really
appreciate your thoughts and insights on
the product uh we didn't want to leave
out your ciso either uh he's got this to
add and what i love about his quote here
is that it really shows how scc premium
brings together both the cloud security
posture management side as well as the
cloud workload protection
capabilities to give your company really
a one-stop shop for all your needs in
protecting google cloud
so i promised announcements and i didn't
forget we've got a couple of new
capabilities that are exciting in the
platform as well as in the hardening and
threat detection sides of the house so
with that a couple of really great
announcements here the first one is that
i've had so many users asking over the
years how they can tune and manage our
systems that i suspect security
engineering is actually full of
musicians
we're rolling out a feature now that
we're calling mute which is essentially
gmail filters for your sec environment
we know that not every one of our
findings is always right for your
environment organizations can have
compensating controls and threat
intelligence is occasionally noisy with
the mute feature teams can easily
silence and control the scope of those
silences to ensure that their findings
cue is full of findings that teams care
about
muting would be really hard to get right
without finding standardization and so
we've standardized attributes across our
different findings with mute we're
simultaneously rolling out new
attributes and making sure that our
vulnerability and threat teams are using
those to give you a consistent
experience as you go through the finding
set
we know that teams already have
workflows for their other security
tooling and we're making it easier than
ever to export scc's findings into your
channels of choice including now your
slack channels of choice uh finally a
big ask for users has been scoped or
delegated views jason and i touched on
their value and using the normal iam
patterns from google cloud teams can now
give teams responsible for projects and
folders insights into the issues
happening in those environments
on the miss config and vulnerability
side we've got some really exciting
announcements as well security health
analytics our real-time posture
management system now supports
user-defined detection this has been a
top ask and we're really excited about
what's now possible i mentioned that
we're bringing in os level cve detection
with our vm manager integration this is
a great collaboration with our friends
over on google compute engine and will
help organizations understand how well
they're doing at the eternal topic of
patching it's a bit like flossing not
exciting not necessarily fun but
definitely among the most important
things you can do to shift your security
outcomes
finally
on the misconfig and hardening front
we're also bringing in detection of cves
in widely deployed applications with a
managed deployment of our open source
tsunami tool now with that on to the
threat detection updates
three areas in event threat detection
and one in container threat detection
google groups is used by most
organizations rather than assign im
roles directly to users roles are
assigned to groups and users belong to
those groups this makes management of
onboarding and off-boarding a lot easier
but there are some gaps and risks that
get introduced by google groups etd has
now integrated with google groups to
give teams findings that highlight when
a group with permissions becomes more
widely joinable as well as when a grant
is made to a group that contains
external members
additionally we've recently released a
set of detection techniques using user
entity behavioral analytics or ueba
it's one of those acronyms that only our
friends at gartner could love but it
describes the general technique of
profiling and detecting deviation from
those profiles we're using it today to
detect account takeover and compromise
for both im accounts as well as service
accounts
on the kubernetes side we're rolling out
a number of new detection modules one
that we released very recently is a
machine learning powered bash script
classifier our general theory of defense
with ktd is to take away from
adversaries entire classes of technique
rather than specific procedures with
this detector we have a robust and
generic approach to detecting malicious
script execution inside of containers it
leverages google strengths in ml and
we're really excited about how it's
performing against production data
already
one more thing we've integrated security
command center premium with chronicle
this is a wonderful case of the teams
truly being better together scc's
real-time threat detection joins
chronicle's powerful investigatory
capabilities
with this integration users can
seamlessly pivot from a fining detail in
security command center into a curated
alert view within chronicle
from there users can investigate the
threat and quickly pivot to associated
actions and events related to the
finding
for example imagine a sock operator
quickly investigating if a principal
observed making a suspicious im grant
had recent login activity or if they
made other suspicious changes after that
im grant
we're really excited about where this
partnership is going beyond ingesting
scc findings chronicle is also ingesting
the stream of cloud audit logs in real
time and pulling cloud asset inventory
metadata to ensure that analysts have
the latest and greatest context when
investigating threats
i know this has been a whirlwind tour of
sec premium our capabilities and what's
new thanks for hanging on if you're
ready to learn more or get started with
scc premium you can check out our
detailed documentation or contact your
account team to get started today we're
here to protect your organization and
we're definitely no use of you if you
can't follow what's going on we take
feedback on these sessions really
seriously so please do fill out the
feedback for the session and let us know
how we can help you better
with that i want to thank you for
joining us for security 209 cloud
posture and workload protection i'm
timothy peacock and i want to thank you
again for taking the time to learn about
how security command center premium
could help your organization with asset
visibility misconfiguration
vulnerability management threat
detection and compliance reporting have
a great day
you